wow
i know
don't you let it make it
don't you
okay
so
um
me
check check my check cbs sync test
check check my check today
is wednesday august 12th 2020
75 degrees outside possible rain
oh yeah did i say today's wednesday sure
is
cbs sync test
oh man
are we good cbs i i don't know yet
don't know yet all right let me keep
talking please all right
um
let's see what we got here
okay
i had uh nugget donuts
and i had a caramel macchiato is my
favorite
caramel macchiato with a sasha's bacon
egg and cheese
delicious i love that um
my name is shawn and uh
everyone six feet apart i like that i
like that item is
draping's good flag's good we got them
all
today's wednesday august 12th
we're about to start in a little while
thank you guys for being here
and i hope all goes well yeah
uh-huh everyone's have your questions
ready
okay be promoted
let's do this right let's do this good
all right thank you
uh
okay
that makes your body move
don't be right all the
with me
in order to
foreign
uh
you ready
can be
oh
uh
come on come on
me
cool
so
so
so
so
take your time you've got to give your
best to be right
all the
you'll have this time one with me
three four five six seven
eight podium check one two
three four five six seven
eight podium check one two
three four five six
seven eight this is a check
of the lectern in case please
one two three four five
six
oh
i'm just waiting to break
you ready
as can be
oh
huh
come on come on
so
do
that makes your body
and i know you'll have this next one
with me
we'll party
in order to move
foreign
detroit
i'm just waiting to break
you ready
as can
can be so sick
huh
three
uh
come on come on
so
i am
all those
do you think i can afford to give you my
love
no
many poor girls
who do you
gonna get think lover
cause when i give my love i want love in
return
tell me
you're never gonna make me cry
tell me
tell me
without
of the world remember
i know
i know we can make it work i know
we can make it
the little children of the world
boys
i know we can make it work i know that
we
can make it
oh
i i know
we can work it out
oh
is
i know
know
oh
ah
foreign
so
three
so
so
hey
my feet
i wanna thank you
hey
uh
thank
let's
you
do
thank you
music
oh
thank you
uh
me
come on
oh
everybody
oh
who's gonna raise me when i'm dead
oh i'm so tired of punching that clock
every
lord day we could use a holiday baby
give it to me
give me the good night
we were born and raised in new york city
fell in love in central park
i really love new york city
still number one
sometimes i feel like i would really
give a damn
if i draw here on the spot
puppy
food
till the sun comes up
cup
oh
baby
please
me
oh
ain't nobody crying
ain't nobody worried ain't no smiling
faces
i'll take you there
i'll take you there
all right
come on
you
i'll take you down
i'll take you there
all right
ah uh
food
please welcome vice president joe biden
and senator
kamala harris
thanks for being here i wish we were
able to talk to the folks outside but
we're
keeping our social distancing and
playing by the rules
good afternoon everyone to me and to uh
come on listen exciting day it's a great
day for our campaign it's a great day
for america in my view
over the past several weeks i've had the
incredible privilege
of meeting and spending a good deal of
time with a group of talented women
leaders
all of whom are qualified to be
president
with each one the more i learned about
them the more i talked to them the more
impressed i was even though i knew them
before
i want to thank each and every one of
them for being part of this process
i look forward to working with them as
we rebuild this country
to get elected and once we are elected
god willing
i approach this with a seriousness of
purpose
and of mind because this is a serious
moment
for our nation we're at one of those
inflection
points you've heard me say that before
in our history
a life-changing election for this nation
and the choice the choice we make this
november
is going to decide the future of america
for a very very
long time and i had a great choice
great opportunities i had
a great choice but i have no doubt
that i picked the right person to join
me as the next vice president united
states of america and that's senator
kamala harris you know and it seems
americans all across this nation
at least at the outset here agree with
me yesterday we had our best grassroots
funders raising day
of the campaign more than double our
previous record
and in doing so we set a single day
record for online political fundraising
and i think i know why
so i hope i hope that you'll join us as
well those of you who listen today
go to joebiden.com today
five dollars ten dollars whatever
kamala as you all know is smart
she's tough she's experienced
she's a proven fighter for the backbone
of this country
the middle class for all those who are
struggling to get into the middle class
kamala knows how to govern she knows how
to make the hard calls
she's ready to do this job on day one
and we're both ready to get to work
rebuilding this nation
and building it better as attorney
general the largest state in the country
commonwealth took on the big banks over
mortgage fraud
and one took on big oil when i wanted to
pollute without consequences
she was a pioneer in marriage equality
and tackle
the gun lobby you know we've all watched
in the united states senate go
toe-to-toe with trump officials
trying to hide the truth asking the
tough questions needed to be asked
and not stopping until she got an answer
and when none was forthcoming it was
obvious
what the answer was as a member of the
intelligence committee
and the judiciary committee she's been
the center
in the middle of the most critical
national security challenges
our country faces well aware
well aware of all the threats to this
nation
and ready to respond to them as a child
of immigrants she knows personally
how immigrant families enrich our
country as well as the challenges of
what it means to grow up
black and indian-american in the united
states of america
her story is america's story different
from mine in many particulars
but also not so different in the
essentials
she's worked hard she's never backed
down from a challenge
and she has earned each and every of the
accolades and achievements that she has
gained many of them often in the face of
obstacles
that others put in her way but never
quit
and this morning all across the nation
little girls woke up especially little
black and brown girls
who so often feel overlooked and
undervalued
in their communities but today today
just
maybe they're seeing themselves for the
first time in a new way
as the stuff of president and vice
presidents
in her campaign in the primary camel
often talked about
what she referred to as the 3am agenda
about moms and dads awake late at night
in their kitchens
worried scared uncertain about how they
were going to take care of their
families about how
they were going to pay the bills about
how they were going to make it
simply make it growing up in scranton
and claim on delaware
i saw that struggle with my family as
well
kamal assault with hers as well and
millions of americans are living that
struggle as we speak
especially in this moment of crisis
especially with so many jobs lost
kamala and i both know
that all folks are looking for as my dad
would say is an even shot
just give me a shot a fair shot
a shot at making it
and it'll be the work of our
administration
to make sure they get a fair shot
working families need someone on their
side in this nation
because they certainly don't have anyone
in the president
now on their side that's going to change
in the biden harris administration
it's going to be gratifying to see the
strong
enthusiastic reaction to senator harris
as our next vice president
you know it comes from people all over
the country it's already occurring
all over the country all ideological
views all backgrounds
events of course we are predictable some
of them
it comes from all over except of course
from donald trump's
white house and his allies you all knew
was coming
you could have set your watches to it
donald trump has already started his
attacks
calling kamala quote nasty
whining about how she is quote mean
to his appointees it's no surprise
because whining is what donald trump
does best better than any president
american history
is anyone surprised donald trump has a
problem with a strong woman or strong
women across the board
we know the more is to come so let's be
clear
if you're a working person worried about
whether or not you'll have a job to go
to
whether or not you'll be able to pay
your mortgage pay your rent
worried about the poison in the air you
breathe the water you drink
worried about your civil rights even
your basic right to dignity
which is under attack with this
administration kamala harris
has had your back and now
we have to have her back she's going to
stand with me in this campaign
and all of us are going to stand up for
her
on january 20th 2021
we're all going to watch senator harris
raise her right hand
and swear the oath of office
as the first woman ever to serve in the
second highest office in america in this
land
and then we're going to get to work
fixing the mess that president trump and
vice president pence
have created both at home and abroad
through four years of mismanagement and
coddling of terrorists
and thugs around the world not only will
america dig itself
out of this hole they've put us in we're
going to build we're going to build back
we're going to build back better
we have a public health crisis while
he's in court trying to do away
with health care with more than 5
million reported infections 165 000
people dead and climbing as a
consequence of cover 19.
and still months later
no real leadership or plan from the
president united states
how to get this pandemic under control
no real help for the states and local
governments trying to fill the vacuum
of leadership from the white house no
real help
for children and educators for small
businesses and front-line workers
that holding their ones holding our
country together
instead he's issuing
executive orders and making promises
that in the end will defund the social
security system
while insisting that this virus will
disappear
the joe biden and kamala harris
administration
will have a comprehensive plan to meet
the challenge of covert 19
and turn the corner on this pandemic
masking clear science-based guidance
dramatically scaling up testing getting
states and local governments the
resources they need to open the schools
and businesses
safely we can do this
we just need a president and vice
president willing to lead and take
responsibility
not as this president says it's not my
fault
the government the governor should thank
me more
as it all saying goes give me a break
we have an economic crisis with more
than 16 million americans
16 million still
out of work donald trump
is on track to break another record
on track to leave office with the worst
jobs record
of any american president of modern
history
but instead of doing the hard work a
meeting face to face
with congressional leaders democrats and
republicans in the white house like
every other president has done in a
crisis
to get americans the relief they need
and deserve
donald trump is on the golf course
if i told you this three years ago you
look at me like i was being crazy
he hasn't even met with the leadership
he doesn't have time it appears
we have a climate crisis that donald
trump refuses to even acknowledge
when he thinks about climate change all
here we hear is
the word hoax
the biden harris administration is going
to meet the climate crisis
protect the health of the american
public
and along the way we're going to deliver
one word
jobs good paying jobs
with a racial cri justice crisis donald
trump seeks only to inflame it
with his politics of racist rhetoric and
appeals to the vision
you know today is not only the day i'm
proud to introduce senator kamala harris
as the vice presidential nominee of the
democratic party
it's also the third anniversary of that
terrible day in charlottesville
remember remember what it felt like to
see those neo-nazis close your eyes
and those klansmen white supremacists
coming out of
fields carrying lighted torches
faces contorted bulging veins
pouring into the streets of historic
american city spewing the same
anti-semitic bio we heard
in hitler's germany in the 30s
remember how it felt to see a violent
clash ensue
between those celebrating hate and those
standing against it
it was a wake-up call for all of us as a
country
for me it was a call to action
my father used to say silence is
complicity
not original to him but he believed it
at that moment i knew i couldn't stand
by and let donald trump
a man who went on to say when asked
about what he thought he said they were
very fine people on both sides
quote very fine people on both sides
no president of the united states of
america has ever said anything like that
see him continue to attack everything
that makes america america
i knew we were in the battle for the
soul of the nation
that's when i decided to run and i'm
proud now to have
senator harris at my side in that battle
because she shares it with the same
intensity i do
or she's someone who knows what's at
stake
the question is for all americans to
answer
who are we as a nation what do we stand
for
and most importantly what do we want to
be
you know someone who knows
that the future of this country is
limited only by the barriers we place
on our own imaginations because there's
nothing americans cannot achieve
when we put our minds to it we do it
together
one of the reasons i chose kamala is
because we both believe
that we can define america simply in one
word
possibilities possibilities let me say
it again
possibilities that's america
that's what sets this nation apart
is that everyone everyone
the ability for everyone and we mean
everyone
to go as far and dream as big
as hard work and their god-given ability
will take them
when i agreed to serve as president
obama's running mate
he asked me a number of questions as
i've asked kamala
the most important was he said to me
what he asked me what i wanted most
importantly
i told him i wanted to be the last
person in the room
before he made important decisions
that's what i asked kamala i asked
common to be the last voice in the room
to always tell me the truth which she
will
challenge my assumptions if she
disagrees
ask the hard questions because that's
the way we make the best decisions for
the american people
i got a chance to spend some time at my
home today
with kamal and doug and i want to thank
them i thanked them and thanked them
publicly
for agreeing to join
and take this journey with jill chillin
me
doug you're gonna have to learn what it
means to be a barrier breaker
yourself in this job you're about to
take on
america's first second gentleman
and all their although they're not with
us here today
i want to thank ellen cole as well i had
a chance to speak to
doug's mom and dad and ellen cole
and uh we're gonna get our kids together
to let them know what what's coming our
my grandchildren are about the age of uh
their children got to speak to them
my campaign has always been a family
affair every campaign i've run
so i've got some news for you
you're all honorary bidens
and here's the best part kamala you've
been an honorary biden for quite some
time
you know i came first to know who kamala
was
through our son bobite they were friends
they served as attorneys general at the
same time
they took the same big they took on the
same big fights together
comment california bow here in delaware
big fights that helped change the entire
country
i know how much beau respected kamal and
her work
and that mattered a lot to me to be
honest with you as i made this decision
so now we need to get to work
pulling this nation out of these crises
we find ourselves in
getting our economy back on track
uniting this nation
and yes winning the battle for the soul
of america
my fellow americans now let me introduce
to you
for the first time your next vice
president united states
kamala harris kamala floor is yours
what do you want there you go
thank you joe thank you joe
as i said joe when you called me i am
incredibly honored
by this responsibility and i'm ready to
get to work
i am ready to get to work after the most
competitive primary in history
the country received a resounding
message
that joe was the person to lead us
forward
and joe i'm so proud to stand with you
and i do so mindful of all the heroic
and ambitious women before me whose
sacrifice
determination and resilience makes my
presence here today
even possible this is a moment
of real consequence for america
everything we care about our economy
our health our children the kind of
country we live in
it's all on the line we're reeling
from the worst public health crisis
in a century the president's
mismanagement of the pandemic
has plunged us into the worst
economic crisis since the great
depression
and we're experiencing a moral reckoning
with racism and systemic injustice
that has brought a new coalition of
conscience
to the streets of our country demanding
change
america is crying out for leadership
yet we have a president who cares more
about himself
than the people who elected him a
president who is making
every challenge we face even more
difficult to solve but here's the good
news
we don't have to accept the failed
government
of donald trump and mike pence in just
83 days we have a
chance to choose a better future
for our country so
joe dr biden
thank you for the trust you've placed in
me
jill i know you will be an incredible
first lady
and my husband doug and i are so
grateful
grateful to become a part of your
extended family
and ever since i received joe's call
i've been thinking
yes about the first biden
that i really came to know and that of
course is joe's beloved son
one of his beloved sons beau
in the midst of the great recession beau
and i spoke on the phone
practically every day sometimes multiple
times
a day working together to win
back billions of dollars for homeowners
from the big banks of the nation that
were foreclosing
on people's homes and let me just tell
you about bo biden
i learned quickly that beau was the kind
of guy
who inspired people to be a better
version of themselves
he really was the best of us and when i
would ask him
where'd you get that where did this come
from
he'd always talk about his dad
and i will tell you the love that they
shared was incredible
to watch it was the most beautiful
display of the love between a father and
a son
and beau talked about how joe would
spend four hours
every day riding the rails back and
forth from wilmington to washington
so he could make breakfast for his kids
in the morning and
make it home in time to tuck them in bed
each night
all of this so two little boys
who had just lost their mom and their
sister in a tragic accident
would know that the world was still
turning
and that's how i came to know joe
he's someone who's first response
when things get tough is never to think
about himself
but to care for everyone else
he's someone who never asks why is this
happening to me
and instead asks what can i do
to make life better for you
his empathy his compassion
his sense of duty to care for others
is why i am so proud to be on this
ticket
and joe and i yes we are cut from the
same cloth
family is everything to me too and i
cannot wait for america to get to know
my husband doug and our amazing kids
colin ella
because whether i'm cheering in the
bleachers at a swim meet
or setting up a college room dorm or
helping my goddaughter prepare for her
school debate
or building legos with my godson or
hugging my two baby nieces
or cooking dinner sunday dinner
my family means everything to me
and i've had a lot of titles over my
career and certainly
vice president will be great but mamala
will always be the one that means the
most
and you know my mother and father they
came from
opposite sides of the world to arrive in
america
one from india and the other from
jamaica
in search of a world-class education
but what brought them together was the
civil rights movement of the 1960s
and that's how they met as students in
the streets of oakland
marching and shouting for this thing
called justice in a struggle
that continues today
and i was part of it my parents would
bring me to protest
strapped tightly in my stroller and my
mother shamala
raised my sister maya and me to believe
that it was up to
us and every generation of americans
to keep on marching she tell us
don't sit around and complain about
things do something
so i did something i devoted my life
to making real the words carved in the
united states supreme court
equal justice under law
and 30 years ago i stood before a judge
for the first time
breathed deep and uttered the phrase
that would that would truly guide my
career and the rest of my career kamala
harris
for the people the people
that's who i represented as district
attorney fighting on behalf of victims
who needed
help the people that's who i fought for
as california's attorney general
when i took on transnational criminal
organizations who traffic in guns
and drugs and human beings and it's the
people who i have fought for
as a united states senator where i've
worked
every day to hold trump officials
accountable
to the american people and the people
are who
joe and i will fight for every day in
the white house
and let me tell you somebody who has
presented my
fair share of arguments in court the
case against donald trump
and mike pence is open and shut
just look where they've gotten us more
than 16 million
out of work millions of kids who cannot
go back to school
a crisis of poverty of homelessness
afflicting
black brown and indigenous people the
most
a crisis of hunger afflicting one in
five
mothers who have children that are
hungry
and tragically more than 165
000 lives that have been cut short
many with loved ones who never got the
chance
to say goodbye
it didn't have to be this way six years
ago in fact we had a different health
crisis
it was called ebola and we all remember
that pandemic
but you know what happened then barack
obama
and joe biden did their job
only two people in the united states
died
two that is what's called leadership
but compare that to the moment we find
ourselves in now
when other countries are following the
science trump pushed
miracle cures he saw on fox news
while other countries were flattening
the curve he said the vice would just
poof go away quote like a miracle
so when other countries opened back up
for business
what did we do we had to shut down
again this virus
has impacted almost every
country but there's a reason
it has hit america worse
than any other advanced nation
it's because of trump's failure
to take it seriously from the start
his refusal to get testing up and
running
his flip-flopping on social distancing
and wearing masks
his delusional belief that he knows
better than the experts
all of that is reason and the reason
that an american dies of covid19 every
80
seconds it's why countless businesses
have had to shut their doors for good
it's why there is complete chaos over
when and how to reopen
our schools mothers and fathers
are confused and uncertain and angry
about child care and the safety of their
kids
at school whether they'll be in danger
if they go or fall behind
if they don't trump
is also the reason millions of americans
are now
unemployed he inherited the longest
economic expansion in history
from barack obama and joe biden
and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground
because of trump's failures of
leadership our economy has taken one of
the biggest hits
out of all the major industrialized
nations with an unemployment rate
that has tripled as of today
this is what happens when we elect a guy
who just
isn't up for the job
our country ends up in tatters
and so does our reputation around
the world but let's be clear
this election isn't just about defeating
donald trump or mike pence it's about
building this country
back better and that's exactly
what joe and i will do we'll create
millions of jobs and fight climate
change
through a clean energy revolution bring
back
critical supply chains so the future is
made
in america build on the affordable care
act
so everyone has the peace of mind that
comes with health insurance
and finally offer caregivers the dignity
the respect and the pay
they deserve will protect a woman's
right to make her
own decisions about her own body root
out
systemic racism in our justice system
and pass
a new voting rights act a john
lewis voting rights act that will ensure
every voice is heard and every voice
is counted the civil rights
struggle is nothing new to joe
it's why he got into public service it's
why he helped reauthorize the voting
rights act
and restore unemployment discrimination
and employment discrimination laws
and today he takes his place in the
ongoing story of america's march
toward equality and justice as only as
the only
as the only who has served alongside the
first black president
and has chosen the first black woman as
his running mate
but as joe always points out this
election
is about more than politics it's about
who we are
as a country and i'll admit over the
past
four years there have been moments when
i have truly worried about our future
but whenever i think that there
is a reason for doubt whenever i've had
my own doubts
i think of you the american people
the doctors and nurses and frontline
workers who are risking
your lives to save others
the truck drivers and the workers in
grocery stores
in factories in farms working there
putting your own safety on the line
to help us get through this pandemic the
women and students
taking to the streets in unprecedented
numbers
the dreamers and immigrants who know
that families belong together
the lgbtq americans who know that love
is love
people of every age and color and creed
who are finally declaring in one voice
that yes black lives matter all across
this country a whole new generation
of children is growing up hearing the
cries
for justice and the chance of
hope on which i was raised
some strapped into strollers of their
own
and trust me it's a song you'll never
forget
so to everyone keeping up the fight you
are doing something you are doing
something great you
are the heroes of our time
and you are the reason i know we are
going to
bring our country closer
to realizing its great promise but to do
it we'll need to work
organize and vote like never before
because we need more than a victory on
november third we need a mandate that
proves that the past few years do not
represent who we are
or who we aspire to be
joe likes to say that character is on
the ballot and it's true
when he saw what happened in
charlottesville three years ago today he
knew we were in a battle for the soul of
our nation
and together with your help that's a
battle we will win
earlier this year i said i do whatever
joe asked me to do
and so now i'm asking you to do the same
so visit joebiden.com to get involved in
this campaign
and vote because electing joe biden is
just the start
of the work ahead of us and i couldn't
be
prouder to be by his side running to
represent you
the people thank you and may god bless
the united states of america
hush nutshell
toward your destination
though you may find some time
convocation
bite your lip
and take the tree
just move on up
by
you